dernier round dernière heure de
négociation pour les marques qui n'ont
pas encore conclu d'accord avec la
grande distribution ce qu'on veut c'est
que chacun prenne sa part et quand on
dit chacun prenne sa part le président
de la République l'a dit lors du salon
de l'agriculture il faut que la grande
distribution prenne sa part elle est
actuellement en négociation avec les
industriels pour essayer de casser des
prix maintenant le président de la
République était au salon de
l'agriculture il était devant les
agriculteurs donc c'était de bonne
guerre
de taper facilement un peu sur les
distributeurs on est la bonne cible à ce
moment-là mais voilà maintenant je pense
que chacun doit faire sa part il est où
votre panier anti-inflation
il est sur la table il est en cours de
discussion d'abord j'ai envie de dire
une chose simple elle est importante à
rappeler je sais que c'est dur Gap en
redressement judiciaire c'est une
nouvelle enseigne détenue par l'homme
d'affaires Michel Ohayon qui s'effondre
vous vous affichez des hausses mais il y
a des matières premières depuis
plusieurs mois qui sont à la baisse et
curieusement dans ces négociations mais
non personne nous parle de baisse donc
ce sont des profiteurs de crise il y a
certains acteurs actuellement qui
cherchent l'effet d'aubaine derrière
cette crise c'est une contre-attaque
éclair celle d'un homme connu pour ne
jamais abandonner malgré une fin de
règne forcée Noël le grec charges
lourdement la ministre des Sports Amélie
ou de la Castéra il dénonce par voie de
presse un matraquage incroyable et une
cabale politique aux médiatique bien
organisée on se la dit moi je
m'interroge sur un tout autre plan c'est
lui qui boit monsieur Noel le grec et
c'est elle qui s'appelle AOC je
comprends pas très bien
je ne l'ai jamais accusé le procureur
qui a décidé souverainement d'ouvrir une
enquête pour des faits de harcèlement
moral et de harcèlement sexuel il me
semble affligent et c'est pas parce
qu'elle prend un temps 12 rue que ça le
rend moins affligent c'est de mentir sur
la réalité des faits la ministre c'était
engagé à rendre public ce rapport et
elle ne l'a pas fait elle a peur de la
vérité il y a une énorme attente du
débat qui va commencer ici demain et ce
d'autant plus que celui à l'Assemblée
nationale qui n'a même pas été jusqu'aux
principal articles à offert un spectacle
parfois désolant cette fois le ministre
du Travail Olivier du socle affirme dans
une lettre aux député socialiste Jérôme
Guedj contre 10 et 20 000 personnes
franchiront réellement ce cap ils ont
été obligés de reconnaître que ils
avaient eu une communication exagérée
mensongère trompeuse ce sera à peine 1
des nouveaux retraités qui bénéficieront
de ce qui était présenté comme la grande
mesure de justice sociale mais vous
dites à raison d'une certaine manière
que le débat et l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas pu aller au bout mais ce n'est
pas au gouvernement qu'il faut en faire
le reproche c'est à vos avis ce sont à
vos alliés de la France insoumise qui
avec 18 000 amendements parfois quelques
outrances le nombre de permis d'aller au
bout notre chiffre du jour à présent
156,7 tonnes de drogue ont été saisis en
2022 des produits stupéfiants pour 2022
et littéralement historique pour le
cannabis 128 tonnes ont été saisis l'an
dernier soit une augmentation de 15%
comparée à 2021 pour la cocaïne 27
tonnes ont été saisis soit 5% de plus
qu'en 2021
passer à l'acte face à l'axe dans ce
genre de d'histoire en fait il n'est pas
pédophile la violence de cette collision
frontale a pulvériser les locomotives et
les wagons de
après l'incendie qui a suivi le choc une
partie des deux trains et carbonisée en
fait nous a montré des vidéos et ces
vidéos il me les a montrées et pourquoi
on vous les a montré
le train de voyageurs rallier la ville
d'Athènes à celle de Thessalonique mais
à hauteur de la ville de Larissa il
percute un train de marchandises
arrivant dans l'autre sens sur la même
voix il a inspiré des générations de
footballeurs juste Fontaine s'est éteint
89 ans il est le seul joueur à avoir
marqué 13 buts lors d'une Coupe du monde
c'était en 1958 le chef de la gare de
Larissa a été arrêté il est poursuivi
pour homicide par négligence